the wraith or laguar woold who would win
in an epic battle to the death i have my
theories and i'm going to tell you all
about them in just a second welcome to
scitrek your sci-fi tv and movie channel
[Music]
ever since target atlantis first hit our
screens and we met the wraith stargate
fans all over the world have been
wondering what it would be like if the
growl and the rave went head to head and
that's what this video is about today
i'm going to be arguing the fact that
the wraith would absolutely annihilate
the guard and on thursday jay is going
to argue the opposite point so let's get
into it what makes me think that the
wraith would absolutely obliterate the
gua would in a head-to-head battle
firstly it's their sheer numbers the
global are very very powerful but
there's not actually a lot of them uh
the bulk of their armies are basically
made up of jafar which are human
which have been turned into incubators
for the larval gua world now they are
not actually garwood themselves
therefore most of the army most of the
forces of the guard world are going to
be based on other life forms whereas
with the wraith it's all made up of
their own species the drone warriors
they are wraith the queens they are rape
pilots that fly the darts that fly the
ships they're all wraith and therefore
with sheer numbers alone they would
absolutely obliterate the gold but let's
imagine that there wasn't that many
wraith about maybe they're on an equal
playing field and there's just as many
wraith as the
i still think the wraith would win and a
large reason for that is the fact that
they are very technologically advanced
and that is
mainly due to the fact that they uh had
technology
from the ancients now much like the goal
the goal technology is based on ancient
technology but
the technology in the pegasus galaxy is
a lot more advanced than it is in the
milky way therefore any technology that
the wraith have salvaged and developed
into their own technology is going to be
a lot more advanced than what the goal
would will have because it's going to
predate any technology that will be
present in the pegasus galaxy
just by
virtue of the fact that the atlanteans
went to pegasus after being in the milky
way and then colonizing it and
developing all their technology the
wraith will have better technology to
start off from than the guar wall did
and the global were very very stagnant
they got their technology they developed
a few things and they didn't really
progress from there the only exception
to that rule would have been anubis when
it became ascended wraith on the other
hand
they figured out how to use space gates
they developed ways to incorporate zpm's
into their ships to create super hives
the technology in the rave dart that
picks people up i believe that was also
originally ancient technology which is
something that the goal would have never
had the best of gold have had in terms
of localized transport
would literally have just been the ring
transporters and they didn't develop
them they literally moved them from one
point to another so they took them from
a pyramid they put them in a ship and
they moved from point a to point b they
moved the locations rather than
developing technology recreate it and
have more of those transports so that
was a very long-winded way of saying
that essentially the wraith had a very
good starting off point in terms of
technology because they're both going to
be based on ancient technology but the
wraith they just have a way bigger head
start now my third reason why i think
the wraith would actually obliterate the
uh the google world is the very
nature of their being they are a hive
mind they have psychic powers and they
can communicate at great distances with
each other this very fact would cement
them in their victory
against the global because they would
instantly find that there is uh a colony
of let's say go all to have entered the
pegasus galaxy maybe they found atlantis
first
who knows maybe they just ventured into
the galaxy unknowingly they stumble upon
the wraith accidentally awakening them
in the pegasus galaxy and obviously
because they're the good old they think
they can beat them and they struck
they're trying to take over what i think
would happen in this situation is the
gold would then just try and take over
the wraith they would
implant symbiotes into the wraith they
somehow captured them and that that
would happen
but because the wraith are so much more
powerful
in terms of their minds because they
have the psychic connections and things
like that
i don't think they would become over
they would be overcome and they would
actually reverse the connection and
instead of the guar wall being able to
take over the wraith the rafe would take
over the guard and access its genetic
memory know everything about the global
know their weaknesses know their plans
no
everything that they're about to do and
they just instantly thwart any incoming
invasions from them i do like the idea
of a wraith uh gold hybrid uh happening
but because of the reasons i've just
said i don't think it would work because
the wraith their minds are just
too powerful they're not normal humans
whether you can just take them over the
eunice where you can just take them over
either they're essentially super evolved
uh humanoid figures with
psychic abilities now those abilities
are something that the girl would have
been seeking for many thousands of years
i think neeti with
the creation of her hybrid humans anubis
was also experimenting in that field as
well but if they actually did it and
they got into a wraith with that kind of
mental power
i don't think the guard would survive i
don't think they're powerful enough to
fight against that kind of power in
their larval form but what do you think
wraith or growled who would win in an
epic battle to the death thank you so
much for watching if you are new to the
youtube channel make sure you hit like
and subscribe and press the bell
notification down below so you don't
miss a single video also whilst you're
down there why not consider becoming a
fully fledged side tracker hit the join
button down below thank you so much for
watching and i will see you next week
[Music]
you